[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا اسمي شيماء
ابراهيم عايزه اكم على حاجه كلنا زمان
عارفين قصه شهيره قوي يعني بنحكيها دايما
للاطفال
الصغيرين هي علاء الدين والمصباح اولاء
الدين والفانوس
مفش ليه كان ده دايما ده الحل يعني ان
علاء الدين ا ما يقابل مشكله يدعك الفانوس
يطلع له العفريت او الجني يحل له المشاكل
والموضوع بينتهي على كده ا الحقيقه انا ا
ما لقيتش
علاء
خالص وما شفتش فوانيس ولا
عفاريت مش عشان انا مش شايفاهم لا ما
تروحوش بناخ ك بعيد بس عشان هم مش موجودين
فعلا ا مش موجودين ليه لانه الحياه كده
فعلا ما هياش بنفس السهوله بتاعه
انه الاقي عفريت او الاقي جن يحل لي كل
مشاكلي انا رقم اين في
اخواتي واول ما جيت
للدنيا كانت صدمه حقيقيه اول صدمه ياخدوها
اهلي في امرهم وجود بيتعاملوا لاول مره مع
حد طفل ما
بيشوفش احنا كمان بنتكلم مش مش من 10 سنين
فاتوا في وقت كانت الناس يعني بدات شويه
تاخد بالها من وجود اشخاص معاقين واهميه
التسليط الضوء عليهم ولا الكلام ده خالص
لا يعني لو كلنا مثلا بنتكلم مش اقل يعني
مثلا من ايه 25 30 سنه بيتكلم في الكلام
ده الكلام ده كان لسه مافيش فيه قوي طيب
الحمد لله على كل شيء اهو نتكيف مع الوضع
وبعد سنتين ثلاثه
اده بالصدمه
الثانيه نفس الكيس ونفس الحاله
بس في صوره ولد
ا طبعا صدمه
تانيه ويعني وصحيح فعلا بدات يعني اهلي
ابويا وامي يتكيفوا وتاقلم مع الوضع ا انا
طفولتي كانت طفوله شويه منعزله لحكم طبيعه
ان مامتي كانت بتشتغل وبابا كان بيشتغل
واخويا الكبير هو اكبر مني برض بثلاث اربع
سنين فعدي يعني هو برض بقى له صحابه وكده
لحد ما انا بدات اكبر شويه بقى عندي حوالي
خمس ست سنين طب ايه بقى بسمع بقى كل شويه
اخويا الكبير المدرسه رايح
جاي عايز مش
عارفه يعني حاجات معينه في المدرسه بيدوه
بيجيبوه طب وانا يعني امتى بقى هبقى عامله
زي ده واخرج واروح وابقى لي اصحابي
والكلام ده
كله كان في نفس الوقت الناحيه التانيه ام
محتاسه ومحتاره الناس دي بتتعلم ما تعلمش
هديهم فين هنعمل لهم ايه وتسمع كلام بقى
من عينه شخ سبيهم في البيت يعني المفتحين
كانوا فلحوا قوي يا شيخ عديهم خلاص كلام
من العينه دي لكن هي يعني عشان هي ام
وعشان هي صاحبه فطره طبيعيه ربنا خلقها
بيها مستسلمتش للوضع والحقيقه يعني هي مش
بس قعدت تدور
على الناس دي يعني ربنا هداها انها تروح
تدور في وزاره التربيه والتعليم وتدور كان
في على المدارس الخاصه بالمعاقين وما الى
ذلك لحد ما ربنا هداها للمدرسه مشكله ان
المدرسه كانت فين بقى انا ساكنه في
المعادي والمدرسه كانت في المهندسين و وده
معناه حاجه دراميه جدا لانها كانت شغلها
في المعادي تروح كل يوم المعادي المهندسين
وال المهندسين
للمعادي وبعدين تروح تاني الظهر برض
المعادي المهندسين وترجعوا
ا لظروف طبعا البيت انا اضطريت في الاول
اول كم سنه قبل ما اخويا يجين نفس المدرسه
يعني ان انا اكون ا ابات في في المدرسه
داخلي ان انا ابات هناك واروح بس خميس
وجمعه ا عايزه احكي لكم ان انا من اول ما
رحت
المدرسه كنت مبسوطه جدا بالعالم الجديد
بالناس الكتير اللي بدات تعرفهم مش كتير
قوي بس بدا على اقل اكتر من نطاق الاسره
والعيله
اي من المواقف الطريفه اللي انا افتكرها
يعني جارتي حتى جارتنا حكيتلي عليها زمان
انه انا كنت مبسوطه جدا لما رحت طبيعي اي
طفل يعني بيروح لاول مره بيعيط بقى وماما
وكده عايزه اقول لكم يعني ان ماما هي اللي
ل مرجت قعدت تعيط وانا
معيطش انا معيطتش كنت مبسوطه جدا بالعالم
الجديد والمدرسه الجديده اللي انا بقيت
فيها
ا بعد شويه يمكن لما كبرت بقى بدات احس
شويه انه لا يعني مش ده البيئه اللي انا
كنت يعني احب ان انا ابقى فيها
ليه المدرسه كانت بالنسبه لي هي مكان
الدراسه ومكان الاكل والشرب ومكان النوم ا
قمه
الانعزال الانعزال في اسوا صوره يعني فجاه
تحسوا كده ان انا بقيت يعني نبات من نبات
الصوبه يعني اللي هو ايه كل حاجه متيسره
والبيئه كلها مجهزه بالشكل اللي يخليني
حاضر يا حبيبتي انت المفروض منك تنجحي
حاضر لازم يعني مدرسه ماشي هتاكلي وتشربي
كل حاجه بس بيقه منعزله جدا ومع ذلك دتني
مكمله الحمد لله كنت شاطره جدا في المدرسه
ماما كانت دايما تشجعني و ودايما كان
عندها رغبه دايما ان لازم اطلع الاولى ما
ينفعش ماطلعش الاولى قتلا يا عيني كان كان
جواها بقى هي يعني حلم او تحدي خدته من
اول يوم قالت لهم انا هودي ولادي الجامعه
وانا هعلم فطول الوقت وهي عندها الامل
والاحساس انه لا يعني انتوا هتستهبل بقى
ولا ايه لازم تشتغلوا على نفسكم وتذكروا
عشان خاطر تطلعوا الاولى
ا المهم انه الحمد لله انا كنت شاطره في
المدرسه وبعد ما خلصت المدرسه كان نفسي
جدا ادخل كليه اعلام وزي ما احنا كنا
بنتكلم دلوقتي على مشاكل التعليم و
والذكاء وغيره انا ضعت مني كليه الاعلام
على درجه في الم درجتين في الم والسون على
درجه في الم قعدت بقى اعيط طب وبعدين هروح
اعمل ايه دلوقتي هروح كده اي حاجه
وخلاص لحد ما دخلت اداب انجلش يعني كان
شيء ريورد شويه مختلف عن بقيه الاقسام
اللي بيدخلوها
الناس و لان طبعا احنا اللي ماعرفش ان في
كليات كتير قوي ممنوعه ان المكفوفين
يدخلوها اصلا في
مصر فما كانش عندي اختيارات كتير دخلت
اداب انجلش وكان اول احتكاك حقيقي بقى ليا
بالواقع بمعنى الكلمه خلاص خرجت بره
الصوبه وبقيت في العالم الحقيقي رحت جامعه
القاهره والظروف شبيهه برده اضطريت ان انا
اقعد في في المدينه الجامعيه والمدينه
الجمعيه ا اللي اللي ما يعرفش مدينه
الجماعيه بتاعه البنات بعد مدان الجيزه
كده بشويه مش مش اللي هي قصاد الجامعه على
طول فده معناه ان انا كان لازم برده اروح
بمواصلات واجيب مواصلات بس انا اخترت دليل
المره دي لانه كان اقرب ولانه مواعيد
الجامعه بتختلف ف النهارده عندي من 10
بكره 12 مش عارف ايه المهم يعني انه كان
لازم اكون في مكان اقرب يكون اسرع في
الحركه الجامعه كان مشكلتها انه ده اول
احتكاك حقيقي بقى زي ما بقول لكم بالعالم
الناس بقى اللي ما تعرفنيش والللي عمرهم
ما شافوا حد معاق في حياتهم والدكاتره
اللي مش عايزين
يساعدوني او اللي منهم عايز يساعد بس خايف
ا حت حتى بيجيبوا لنا الناس ساعات يكتبوا
لنا في الامتحانات كانت مسايه يعني انا من
المواقف اللي اذكرها مثلا كان عندي مره
امتحان وكانوا جايبين لي واحده تكتب لي
كان حاجه امتحان علم نفس حاجه كده
وبعدين كان في رمضان فانا ببراءه شديده
جدا بقول لها بتقول لي ايه انت مذاكره بقى
ولا هتضيعي لنا الوقت مش قادره اقول لكم
يا جماعه يعني حسيت ان هو يعني التون رايه
وسكينه يعني
مش قلت لها طيب ان شاء الله مذاكره يعني
قالت لي طيب يلا عشان احنا نخلص ونرا
تخيلوا يعني انتب في التنشن ده كله وحد
بيقول لها كده وبعدين قلت لها ليه ببراءه
برض مصره على البراءه وحضرتك ساكنه فين
قالت لي انا ساكنه فين باب قلت لها يا ده
انا ساكنه في المعادي قالت لي ايوه بس انا
هروح اطبخ انت هتروحي
تطبخي بعد شويه ده كان بس يعني ده ناهيكم
بقى طبعا عن صعبات ان انا اروح الجامعه كل
يوم نهي عن صعوبات مثلا زي انه نسجل الم
محاضرات و ما تنفعش المحاضرات تتسجل تبوظ
لاي سبب من الاسباب ناهيكم عن اصحابي اللي
قرروا مره ما يروحو الجامعه في يوم انا
كنت محتاجه اروحه جدا عشان خاطر في
محاضرات كتير كانت الدنيا بتمطر وقرروا يا
سيخه بقى يعني ما حدش هيروح يا شيماء مش
مشكله ما الدكاتره مش هيجوا انا قررت ان
انا اروح ودي فرصه اقول لكم برض ان اللي
عايز يعمل حاجه بيعملها على فكره المهم
رحت رحت الجامعه حتى ادور بقى على اي حد
واحده خارجه حتى لو كانوا رايحين قصر عيني
مش مهم يوصلوني في اقرب حته وحد يسلم حد
لحد ما وصلت الجامعه ودخلت وحضرت
والدكاتره كلهم جم في اليوم ده طعت بقى
بكل الفرحه اللي جوايا والشماته الصراحه
بجت رجعت ليهم عشان اقول لهم على فكره هم
وجوم كلهم ما اجوم كلهم اه
تخيلوا
وعدت الايام وخرجت
الجامعه وبعدين بقى نعمل ايه بديه اي حد
طبيعي بس انا برض ساعات بفكر افكار غريبه
قوي يعني مش في المجتمع للاسف محتاجين
نشتغل عليها شويه عادي بقى انا بفكر زي اي
حد عايز اشتغل طبعا انه المعاقين يشتغلوا
مازالت قضيه كبيره جدا لحد دلوقتي
ف لقيت نفسي بحلم احلام غريبه قوي ازاي دي
ده تشتغل اصلا رحت بقى قعدت ادور برده انا
ومامتي بمناسبه انا عايزه احيي ماما جدا
على فكره لان الست
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دي لانه هي كان ليها دور مهم في حياتي
كبير وكان وزال طبعا ربنا يخليها لي يا رب
ويديها صحه رحت بعد كده ادور على الشغل
طبعا الناس مرضوش كتير بقى اللي يقول لي
حبيبتي على المدارس بتاعتك خليهم يشوفوا
لك شغله واللي تقولي يهرب
من كده مظبوط اوكي ا واللي ما يرضاش يه
ويهربوا مني وما يردوش اصلا يقابلوه خلاص
قررت بقى وعياط عياض فعلا يعني ايه يعني
خلاص بقى انا استنى موتي يعني ايه خلاص
كده الحياه انتهت وعياض بقى يا جماعه وما
فيش اكل وبطل اكله واكتئاب حقيقي يعني كل
الناس بتروح شغلها وانا الوحيده اللي قاده
في البيت ما بعملش حاجه وخلاص لحد ما بدا
يعني ينتشر شويه في حياه المكفوفين
استخدام الكمبيوتر واللي ما يعرفش يا
جماعه الكمبيوتر المكفوفين بيستخدموه
بيستخدموه من خلال برامج قراءه شاشه بتقرا
لهم كل حاجه الله ايه ده دي حاجه حلوه قوي
طب ده ممكن نعمل بيه ايه ده قت ادور طب
اجيبه ازاي اول كمبيوتر جبته في حياتي كان
ب 3000 جنيه وساعتها ده كان مبلغ محترم
قعدت قعدت ادور اه ساعتها يعني مش دلوقتي
قعدت ادور على كل حاجه بقى فلوس محوشها من
العاديه على مش عارف كان فلوس من ايام
الجامعه واجيب من هنا واجيب من هناك ماما
تديني برض مش عارفه قد كذا لحد ما جبته يا
جماعه الموضوع كان بالنسبه لي بقى
اتشيفمنت يعني بدات اتعلم الكمبيوتر
واصاحب ناس عندهم برض نفس الاعاقه يمكن
سابقني كانوا شويه وده تتعلم من خلالهم من
خلال غيرهم الكمبيوتر على الانترنت وان في
البيت اتعلم
ولعبت ودخلت على الانترنت وبدات اتكلم في
سكايب واتعرف على اصحاب واصحاب يعرفوا
اصحاب وهكذا لحد ما بقت الموضوع لطيف ورجع
السؤال تاني وبعدين عامل ايه بقى يعني
خلاص يعني خلصنا يعني اه ان سوت يعني انا
هدني بقى قاده كده قدام الكمبيوتر طول
النهار والليل فج السؤال لحد ما فتره من
الفترات واحده كنت اعرفها من ضمن بقى
الناس اللي انا عرفتهم على عن طريق
الانترنت وطبعا يعني هي كانت معرفه موظفه
اكيد مش اي حد وخلاص يعني كانت هي ست
بتشتغل في جمعيه خاصه بالمعاقين
بصريا في في رام الله وقالت لي طب بصي
احنا عندنا حاجات كتير بنعوز ترجمه طب
تقدري تترجمي لنا ونحاسبك يعني قلت لها
حاضر ماشي وترجمت والشغل عجبهم
جدا وكانت الفلوس رغم اللي كانت قليله
ساعتها بس يعني اي و سو هابي انه اول مره
اشتغل يا جماعه يعني ده ده اتشيفمنت يعني
عجبني الموضوع وبدات ان انا ادور على طب
الموضوع حلو هو خلاص انا بدات ادرس بقى
درست في الايو سي عملت ترانسليشن بشن سفيك
في الترانسليشن كلها جج ترانسليشن يو ان
حاجات كده خلاص طالما الناس مش مقتنعه بي
اشتغل من وراء
القدان وده في البيت وماحدش عارف بقى مين
ايه وخلاص وانا هديهم الشغل وخلاص المهم
انه فعلا بدات اعمل كده وبدا يجيلي شغل
وما يجيلي ويعني مشي الحال
ا وبعدين بقى نعمل ايه دلوقتي يعني اه
يعني في حاجه كده يعني يعني مش هسكت بقى
مافيش امل يعني لازم فيو بعدين اوكي ما
عنديش ما عنديش شغل كتير ساعات بيجي
وساعات ما بيجيش عشان الفريلانسينج طبيعته
كده المهم عن طريق واحده صاحبتي عرفت شركه
شركه من شركات الانترنت في مصر اشتغلت
عندهم قعدت حوالي تقريبا لاث سنين
ونص كنت بشتغل في الماركتين وكان في
بدايات حاجه اسمها الديجيتال ماركت حاجه
بقت بوم الناس ها بتتكلم عليها الكلام ده
بنتكلم عليه في 2008 مثلا عجبني جدا
الموضوع وبدات اشتغل وهو قاللي ساعتها
اشتغلي على نفسك وتعلمي الموضوع ده
وفيدينا
بيهم خلال الثلاث
سنين
برضو كان في وبعدين طالعه في حته
يعني طب انا بشتغل وبعدين بقى انا عايزه
اكون جزء من المجتمع عايز اعمل حاجه يا
جماعه يعني في حاجه دايما كده واقفه جوايا
يعني وفي وبعدين
دايما قررت ان انا
عايزه في
منحه الله يعني بسمع طول عمري بقى على
البلاد اللي بره وبيعملوا حاجات كتير
للمكفوفين ومش عارفه ايه يعني توتال
ديفرنت وبره الناس بيفكروا بشكل مختلف
عايزه اعمل زيهم بعدين قررت ان انا اقدم
على المنحه هتسافري امريكا يا
لهوي تجننت يا
[تصفيق]
بنت طبعا ده كان لسان حال يعني كلام كتير
قوي زي ما امينا كانت بتحكي كده اللي هو
يعني كمان يعني انت عايزه تسافري لوحدك
يعني نفس السؤال بقى بتاع زمان ههم
المفتحين عارفين يسلكوا بنفسهم هنا لما
تسلكي انت بره
لوحدك طبعا الكلام كان مرفوض تماما بس انا
قررت ان انا لازم اسافر قررت عشان اثبت
كذا حاجه اولا لان دي فرصه ممكن ما تجيش
تاني تاني حاجه ان انا كنت عايزه اثبت ان
انا اكتر من كائن كمبيوتر مش انسان قي
قاعد على الكمبيوتر طول الوقت انا بني ادم
عايز اشوف الدنيا وبتاثر بيها واكون جزء
من
وفعلا يا جماعه سافرت ورحت امريكا ورحت
جامعه نيويورك اكبر واحده من اكبر جامعات
العالم عملت ماجستير في الماركتنج وتحديدا
في التسويق الالكتروني او الديجيتال
ماركتنج اللي انا كنت عايزه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعمله المهم في وسط الري كان في برض حاجات
غريبه بتطلع يعني داما وبعدين قاعده برض
مستنياني وانا في امريكا كان في مشكله
قابلتني انه رئيسه القسم قررت كن اول حد
كفيف يدخل الكليه عندها وقررت ان مش
عايزاني بعد تقريبا شهر من وجودي في
المكان ليه مش عايزاني قتلي ببساطه كده في
الميت
قالتلي
يك وات
ه فعلا يعني الموضوع كان سوي جدا انا طلعت
من عندها يعني هي كانت سحباني على
الاسانسير معرفش كانت يعني اللي هو عارف
كانت هترميني في النار او حاجه الست كنت
انا بمثلها حاجات كتير قوي وحشه يعني انا
كنت بالنسبه لها عربيه
وكفيفه ومحجبه وحاجه يعني كولكشن كده غريب
جدا
[موسيقى]
يعني ودنست تاين بقى في عز الخناقات
والزحمه دي كلها جالي يعني اقس في حدث في
عمري في عمري كله حصل لي لحد
دلوقتي هو وفات بابا الله يرحمه جا عشان
يكمل يكمل عليا بقى بمعنى الكلمه يعني
القساه دي يا جماعه كان هو تقريب وهو
حبيبي كان عارف انه هي مضايقاني ويقوللي
طب هتعملي ايه يا بنتي طب مش عارف ايه
الكلام ده كله كان الموضوع صراحه تف
جدا وطريت ان انا اجي مصر كل الناس برض
قعدت تقول بقى هي المره دي وبعدين هي
هتكمل مش هتكمل طب كان الكلام ده يمكن
بعدها بثلاث شهور ولا حاجه بعد ما سفرت
والحقيقه كملت كان جوايا رغبه ان انا اكمل
حلمه اللي بداه معايا ان انا ابقى حاجه
كويسه كان فرحان جدا وبنتي هتسافر امريكا
وهتتعلم ووالى اخره كان فرحان قوي وكان
عنده احساس كان دايما يقول لهم لما يقولوا
له الكلام اللي قلته لكم من شويه ايوه انا
هسيبها تشق طريقها عشان انا مش هعيش لها
طول العمر وكانه كان عارف ان هو ثلاث شهور
بالظبط وفعلا هيسيبني لوحدي وهيمشي
كملت ورجعت تاني وقلت لهم وبعدين بعدين
بالنسبه لي كت انا لازم اكمل ولازم انجح
ولازم اثبت لهم واثبت له ان انا كنت اهل
للمسؤوليه وحتى اثبت للكليه هناك اللي على
فكره مايه الست رئيسه القسم وانا اللي
قعدت في القسم يعني
الحقيقه اه يعني المصري مفتري طول عمره
قوي وجبار يعني مطرح ما
يروح
ونجحت
وكان برض في سؤال غريب جدا
وبعدين رجعت مصر فعز بقى الازمه قبل 30/6
وما اعقب وما قبل يعني كل الناس بقى اللي
هو ايه كانهم بيعزوني حبيبتي ايه اللي
جابك في الوقت ده بس يعني هو اصلي يعني بس
لو انت يعني ايه انا كنت فين وبقيت فين
ومش عارفه ايه والكلام ده كله المهم انه
بعد شويه بعد سنه حد من اصحابي كان شايف
ستتس على الفيسبوك كلها كابه فصعب بت عليه
وقاللي
هاتي السي في بتاعتك وحاولي اوديها ل هو
يا جماعه يعني ازاي يعني واحده انا خريجه
جامعه نيويورك ومعايا ماسترز وبعرف
كمبيوتر وحاجات كتير مهمه وفي الاخر ما
ينفعش ازاي يعني ان انا ما اشتغلش يعني
لسه برض يعني اروح وارجع ولسه نفس الافكار
هي هي المهم رحت فعلا وعملت كل الحاجات
واشتغلت دوقتي الحمد لله في احدى الشركات
الكبرى يعني في مجلات البروفيشنال سيرفيسز
والحمد لله ازوى ان هم مبسوطين مني يعني
ان شاء الله حتى كان التير بتاعنا بيقول
يعني انه انا من اكتر الناس اللي عنده
بروتيفيتي
ساب عل بقى في بعدين تانيه انه انا بقى
دوري بقى الدنيا اللي انا شفتها بره نفسي
اشوفها هنا بشكل او باخر ف جويند واحده من
المؤسسات اللي انا بعتز بيه جدا وانا اكتف
ممبر معاهم هما حلم فاونديشن مؤسسه حلم
لتمكين زوي الاحتياجات الخاصه ودو
الاعاقه عشان نكمل مع بعض حلمنا بقى وحلمي
اللي هو لازم اللي احنا بنشوفه بره يطبق
هنا في مصر بشكل من الاشكال ودايما كان في
سؤال ج تاني وعايزه اقوللكم ان انا دلوقتي
في كومفرت زون بعد ما الحمد لله بقى ل دور
في الكوميونتي وبروفيشنال ماشيه كويس
واكاديمي لتالي حققت حاجات مش وحشه
وان دلوقتي في مرحله تب
وبعدين
ه